okay so just be upfront best part of
this is the fact that the doctor gets
referred to as the nurse so this is a
patreon sponsored review and even though
those are soon going to be migrating
over to the break room of geeks I wanted
to put this one up here because I've
definitely got things I need to say
about it that I feel that it should be
said on the bigger platform so I was
commissioned to review a Doctor Who book
which I haven't done reviews on before I
don't really get into that sort of thing
normally I enjoy Doctor Who Big Finish
and obviously I'm working my way through
classic but books comics things like
that mmm for the most part I I skip that
sort of thing but this is a 13th Doctor
story so it has Graham Ryan gasps and it
is called the good doctor and the plot
is it has to do with basically the
doctor and companions it opens with them
negotiating or assisting in the
negotiation of a truce between two
warring factions on this planet
basically human and what are called
Lobos which are dog people and the and
so they negotiate this peace between
them they end up back on the same planet
sometime later and find that an entire
religion has sprung up worshipping the
good doctor except the good doctor isn't
the doctor the good doctor that they're
worshiping is Graham
and there is oppression going on there's
rebellion and so on
so there's your basic set and as far as
doing this sort of story it does it
pretty well because it's not exactly a
unique story in the world of science
fiction especially science fiction TV
shows I'll sort of address that a little
bit later and it has the advantage of
being able to take a little bit more
time and not have to rush it's I am Not
sure it adds a lot more depth to this
sort of thing then you would get out of
like a 45 minute or you know it maybe
even a two-parter at a stretch
but it does you know get to slow down
the pacing so that things can take a
little longer feel perhaps a little bit
more earned it's it's pretty well
written as far as the writing goes the
voices of the characters are captured
quite well and reliably so it's very
much in the tone and everything of
Doctor Who it's consistent so why do I
hate this the first thing I need to say
is I don't hate this because of anything
having to do with the fact that it's
Doctor Who I hate this because I am so
beyond sick of this plot but more than
that I'm infuriatingly done with this
attitude within science fiction so what
do I mean by this well first of all this
plot any science fiction show that
involves landing on other planets
nearly inevitably eventually does the
natives of a planet think that the main
characters the travelers the people who
can actually move between worlds are
gods or one person in particular is a
god every single sci-fi series has done
this plot and this does not bring
anything
new to the table it is exactly what you
would think it is it is the
misappropriation of what certain things
that the good dr. Graham said and miss
applying them a bunch of made-up stuff
that didn't even happen at all and you
know the reality of the person that your
religion is based on not living up to
your concept of what that person is
supposed to be all of that's here all
that's in place completely standard
unexcited but that's not why I hate it
the reason I hated the reason I am so
sick of this plot in science fiction is
because it is so hard it is dang near
impossible to find a science fiction
story especially anything that's been
long-running that is not insanely
condescending and belittling and just
cruel towards the idea of faith and
people who have it now first off I don't
actually really have much of a dog in
this race I'm not a person of faith I
don't practice any religion I wasn't
raised in a religion I didn't go to
church growing up I don't go to church
now so I'm not personally offended in
the sense that hey you I feel like I'm
being attacked but I do feel insulted
and I feel like this has gone on for way
way way too long because the points
being made about religion about the
application of religion about how it can
be used as a tool of oppression about
how details can be flexed to build and
then maintain a power structure about
how much of it is just flat-out made-up
it's not that these are invalid points
it's just these are the exact same
freaking points every single sci-fi show
that has ever done this plot which feels
like it's all of them does heck you
don't even need to have an involve
religion to have it be the same friggin
plot Firefly did the same plot with
janestown and instead of it being they
were submitted as a god it's they
worship Him as a folk hero but it's
still the same freakin story with the
same the he doesn't match up to the
legend that they built of him and they
have this whole story about what he did
and that's not at all what what he did
it's so it's the exact same friggin plot
without the without the religion in
there and I didn't like that either that
is one of my least favorite episodes of
Firefly cuz I've seen it before but the
minute you bring the religion back into
it and you start having this attitude
it's it's infuriating and it's
small-minded and it's petty
whenever religion is brought up in
science fiction those who have faith are
treated as one of three things stupid
naive which is the nice version of
stupid or awful either they believe
wholeheartedly which is treated as a
mental deficiency practically they're
primitive and they don't understand
better they're dumb those are your true
believers you have the followers who may
not be as deeply committed but they
don't question it because that's just
how they were raised they're not they're
the naive ones nicer version of stupid
and then there's the ones who maybe they
realize it's not everything that they
say it is or maybe they also believe but
they're gonna use it as - to their
advantage ie they're gonna be the
Spanish Inquisition because they always
base this crap when they go that
direction they always basis crap
the friggin Spanish Inquisition why does
science fiction have this position that
interstellar travel obliterates faith
that's incredibly narrow-minded
especially when you are dealing with
other planets other beings other ways of
thinking maybe a lot of the concepts of
faith and God and whatever that we have
here on earth
don't translate to once we start when
and if we ever start going out for a
little counter another species but that
doesn't mean that there isn't a faith
that can accommodate that that can be
rational I'm not a person of faith but I
have friends who are and they are smart
they're intelligent people they are
compassionate people they're not idiots
they haven't been tricked they haven't
been duped that's not what faith is
faith can be misused and it can be used
to twist and control it I'm not saying
it can't I am NOT denying that that is a
thing that has and does happen but for
depictions of faith and anyone with
faith in science fiction that is always
shown to be that it is virtually never
shown in a positive or even a neutral
light faith can be misapplied faith can
be faith can be used wrong but you can
also be an intelligent understanding
person who believes in science and
believes in evolution and also believes
in God those are not contradictory
concepts
and to treat them like they are is to be
so unbelievably patronizing that I just
find it insulting and it's something
that I'm not going to go so far as to
blame the pervasiveness of this sort of
thing in science fiction on the whole
atheist phenomenon but it doesn't help
because it fosters a culture among geeks
who fancy themselves as more imaginative
and more intellectual we're the idea of
believing in any kind of how our higher
power is seen as a deficiency and that
is not a way they you should be looking
at the world and I'm not gonna be so
insulting us to say anyone who has ever
seen his story words to pick you like
that
therefore they see religion like that no
I'm not gonna be that condescending but
I'm gonna say that the ubiquity of that
perspective from a genre that I love
pisses me off
this is something I've brought up at
various points where it's come up before
they mentioned it in my fires of Pompeii
review
yeah that's an episode I really like of
Doctor Who I'm really glad the show
itself has never done this plot at least
so far as I'm bored nothing that I've
seen if they did it at some point in
classic I haven't gotten to it yet aside
from the fact that this plot is tropi
and tried and stale it's just so damn
insulting again it's not a bad book it's
a perfectly good book and my issue is
less with this specific book and I
certainly don't have a problem with this
writer but I never want to see this
story again in sci-fi I'm sick of it
it's the story of every time religion
gets tackled in sci-fi and I am done I'm
done with it the same way that I'm done
with romantic subplots just
don't do it unless you've got a truly
unique take on it if you're gonna do the
same thing that we always see stop there
you go my angry rant on the depiction of
faith in science fiction as spurred on
and put through the lens of the novel
Doctor Who the good doctor what are your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it if you have examples that don't
match what I've said I would love to
hear them I've heard that there was some
decent handling of faiths and things
like Babylon 5 and the revived
Battlestar Galactica like to go but I
haven't Percy seen it out of those I
can't vouch for them there's also the
usual stuff to do like subscribe find me
on Twitter maybe all that usual stuff
yeah I got a patreon link in the
description you don't have to do any of
that though end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]